you know what I realize you get high
enough most things look like food
yeah check this out go to YouTube search
uh cow hoove treatment yeah just click
any one of these it's kind of like
coconut that's all I was about to say
get deep enough in this video it's gonna
look like coconut if you just skipped
like five minutes like coconut like if
you just if you just zoned it that looks
like you're cutting into some Manchego
yeah that does yeah you're right you're
high enough absolutely right just and if
you just you know you cropped out all
the disgusting around it you'd be like
what pasta is this I mean surprise cow
what are these cows constantly [__]
stepping on that they're getting these
infections in their in their Hood uh
don't cows just like stand there and
[__] on themselves no kidding I mean if
you just stood and shat and pissed on
your feet all day I'm sure at some point
you're gonna get an abscess yeah